Want to do what's called a dual stack deployment. In a dual stack deployment a
host can speak both IPv4 and IPv6. It
communicates with an IPv4 host using IPv4 and
communicates with an IPv6 host using IPv6.
What this means is that the dual stack
host has to have an IPv4 compatible address.
Either the host has both an IPv4 and
an IPv6 address, thus allowing it to speak to an IPv4 host or it must rely
on a translator, which knows how to take a v4 compatible IPv6 address,
and translate it, to the v4 address. One possible way of ensuring compatibility,
of a v6 address with IPv4, is simply to embed the IPv4 address, in 32 bits of
the 128 that are allocated for the IPv6 address. Now, a dual stack post
configuration or a v4 compatible IPv6 address solves the problem of post
IP address assignment, but it doesn't
solve the problem that IPv6 deployments might
exist as islands. For example, multiple
independent portions of the Internet might deploy
IPv6, but what if the middle of the network only speaks in routes IPv4? The
solution here is to use what's called 6 to 4 tunneling. In 6 to 4 tunneling,
a v6 packet is encapsulated in a v4 packet. Now, that
v4 packet Is routed to a particular v4 to v6 gateway
corresponding to the v6 address that lies behind that gateway.
And at this point the outer layer of
encapsulation can be stripped, and the v6 packet
can be sent to its destination. This of
course, requires the gateways at the boundaries between
the v4 and v6 networks to perform encapsulation
of the packet as it enters the v4
only part of the network, and decapsulation as
the packet enters the v6 island, where the destination
host resides.